hello everyone hello hello i just woke up from my nap all
right let me make sure you guys are on the screen don't
worry it takes me a while to rev up it's like start like i
always say it's like starting an engine i just got i just i
was busy busy busy last two days oh who is that doing
Pastoki, curse you.
Pastoki, you've done it again, pastoki.
Why do you never think of future, Doki?
Why?
Why do you always do this to future, Doki?
There it is.
Why did you decide to stream past, Doki?
When will she ever learn?
Past Doki is like, that's future Doki's problem.
Not knowing future Doki is me now!
Past Doki never thinks of future Doki.
Yeah, I just, uh, I just woke up from my nap.
From my nap.
Also, any member goons right now.
Okay, so I'm going to leave.
leak member streams that's right i'm the leaker i'm the
leaker of the streams so for those who don't know we had
like uh our pal world server um was lagging really really
bad even with like because you know everybody started
building stuff and everything and uh and context wise like
uh uh wait you can't do that um so people were rubber
banding and stuff um and i didn't realize how uh uh until i
we were streaming the server today and then i was like guys
let's see if we could upgrade like see if i can pay more
money and get us a like upgrade like uh like let me see or
the hosting site let me look at the lowest hosting site
maybe there's like like additional dlc upgrades i could buy
so the servers would be less laggy because i didn't realize
how laggy it was getting
So I was just like, alright, and I realized, wait, I can't
pay more money for this.
There's no options.
There's no options for me to pay more money to have a better
server, to upgrade like, you know, RAM or something.
Get more RAM to like, or like any like CPU upgrades or
anything for the server.
So I was a little confused.
I was like, oh, how come I was just like, oh, what do you
mean I can't fix this with money?
like what do you mean I have the money why can't I just
throw money at a problem for it to be fixed so then I was
like guys I have an idea because I was I was using like
broccoli service uh and I was like guys I can join their
discord server and I can file a ticket and ask them if they
could give like where I can pay to upgrade the server and
then I'll tell them I'm a really big streamer I have 900k
subscribers and then we'll see what happens.
And then my chat was didn't believe in me.
The member goes didn't believe me.
That's not gonna work, Doki.
They're not gonna, they're not gonna do anything.
That's such a stupid idea.
And guess what, what happened?
Guess how that stupid, how that stupid idea panned out,
guys.
Also look at the message I sent.
It might be also because they said it was a stupid idea.
Because how I wrote this message.
Because I was streaming.
So I wasn't like.
So this is basically the message I wrote.
Is there a way to pay more for more RAM for my streamer
server.
That half of my viewers.
It's currently lagging.
Because there's too many buildings.
I'm willing to pay.
Dollar sign.
I have 900k subscribers.
and my then the mega Ragoos was like no why would you why
are you flexing your money and and like that's how you do it
like that what's the point of having what's the point of
having money and also the number of subscribers if I can't
flex it to get us opportunities guys I'm doing for you guys
like like guys Dragoons I'm doing this for you like
Like, written, I mean business.
I, yeah, no, I'm doing that.
So, I was like, I'm trying to do this for you guys.
Tokey Raven got a job for you.
Saber, thank you for the Saber chat.
Thank you, thank you.
and um and so i and so because i was like we were lagging
really hard so i was like i have to i have to like uh i was
like trying to figure out what to do to improve the server
and then and now we have we accidentally stumbled onto a
partnership with the server hosting site by accident
love the sleepwear oh you got a good rest in it see asking
works you always got a your shot guys yes so anyway now I
have a partnership with the server hosting site and we
thought we got V VIP treatment because they were like yeah
they were like yeah we can move you we can transfer your
server to better hardware and it should significantly
improve the server so and then later so we've so we upgrades
at first it was like uh at first they were like we're gonna
transfer your server uh to uh to a better uh hardware and it
should be significantly better
i'm willing to make dollars so i should have added another
extra dollar sign you're right i have a bunch not thank you
for the super chat that you think i have 900k subscribers
Sounds like something a scammer would open up with.
A good tip.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Next time I need something done, I'm going to flex time
subscribe to someone with 900,000 subscribers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, they were like, let's see, what did they say?
They were like, hey, we're going to move you to better
hardware.
port's gonna change but the heart but uh it's the best
hardware we offer with that kind of player account and it
worked it worked and then later on i was like should i push
for more guys because we got a lot we got the transfer over
um and we're thinking this super chat thank you thank you
anyway and then so we gotta transfer over and then um we
locked back in all the member goons and back in.
And then I was like, guys, how is it?
Some were like, oh, we're still lagging a bit, but like the
rubber batting is significantly an improvement.
So now I was like, all right, let me do this.
So I was like, thank you.
The people who are in said it's definitely an improvement.
Some are still lagging a little bit, but it's definitely a
lot better than before.
So no more rubber batting now.
So that's a good sign.
And then they were like,
And our server is now being used as a test subject for some
optimizations coding that one of the staff member is working
on.
So apparently it's implemented now, guys.
So if you are in the PowerWorld server, please feel free to
stress tests.
in the PAL world server, please let me know how it's going.
I don't know what that means.
Oh yeah, I was like, guys, they're gonna give us
multi-threading.
I don't know what that means, but that sounds good.
But don't stress, don't like ultra stress test the server.
Just play it as how you're playing it.
Just play it normally, guys.
Just let me know if it doesn't feel...
Okay, so anyway, they asked for an update.
That's why I'm, like, talking about it.
Huge shout-out to Indifferent Broccoli for the great staff,
for the great service, help desk, and everything.
Really great.
Legitimately, I did not think that they would go above and
beyond.
Sorry, my help ticket was, like, half-jokingly rode.
Like, I...
All right, to be fair, I sort of did wrote that help ticket
as like half content, you know, so I didn't think it
actually worked.
So shout out to Indifferent Broccoli for going above and
beyond in the help desk with the help ticket.
And actually, yeah, it was supposed to be like half a shit
post.
You know, I literally wrote, I have dollar sign, dollar
sign, dollar sign.
to be a shit post I didn't I didn't realize for that to
actually work so huge huge shout out and thank you to the
staff there thanks for enabling my child you never know
never hurts the ass guys it really doesn't hurt the ass I so
and and in the end we got try and upgrade we got a I can't
help it.
Whenever I'm like streaming, I'm just like, it's like the
shit post calls for me.
Like, it's like a green goblin mask.
Like, you're like, think of the content.
Dokey, you know you want to put an extra dollar sign in
there.
Think of the content.
If I was off stream, I wouldn't have wrote it like that.
But because I was on stream, I was just like, I, like my
content brain was on.
I am my own mask It'll be so funny, Joki You should put
another dollar sign Tell them about your subscriber numbers
I was like, I should I should put that down I
Sorry Um Sorry, I don't know what came over me But yeah Um
So If anyone in the PAL world server, is everything okay?
Because they do want me to give them an update right now of
whether or not the PAL, like, how the...
Has the V-VIP treatment worked for the server?
Doki, please don't break the server when you order all
dragon goons to battle Royale the last day.
Literally, get loud here.
Are you not entertained?
Let's thank you for the super chat.
same as no multi-threading it's like when you tweet a theory
yeah but we got didn't get ads here from it sometimes it
just doesn't work and sometimes it works too well but it's
improving
all right so i'll tell them that it's five so kind of
struggles all right uh i'll tell it uh just just asked my
viewers they said it's improving but when there's 20 plus uh
let's see what is it uh it kind of struggles i'll write that
um but but a huge in but a lot better before any before the
hardware move um before and or any other improvements added
all right i wrote uh uh siren thank welcome to tomato farm
welcome welcome all right so yeah that's the thing i wanted
to leak from the member stream it was um they all saw it
happening live i was like get ready guys we're gonna move
now.
We're in the great move.
Yo, it's night and day.
Like, I was rubber batting a I was rubber batting a bit.
I was rubber batting a bit when I logged in.
I was like, oh, shit.
Has this been like, we reset the server before I got into.
So I was like, guys, has this been like this entire time?
I'm so sorry.
I did not realize it was that.
It was that.
bad and they're like yeah and I was like don't worry guys I
I will fix this daddy dokey is here it's okay child oh shit
wait the staff wants to go get oh my god guys the staff was
like can we can I jump on the server so I can look at the
metrics and see what's wrong oh my god they're gonna
personally go into the and study our data now.
Oh my god.
And Dean's finally doing her job.
The V, V, VIP.
Guys, we made it.
Guys, the V, V, VIP treatment.
We're here.
Don't let them fill the server.
Saber, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
We are the guinea pigs.
They're going to see the stairway that happened.
They're going to see, sorry, they built the tower of Babylon
in the server.
So that might be the cause of all the lag.
We don't know yet.
How many bees can it go?
Yeah.
All right.
It's fine with me.
They're gonna study our data, guys.
They're saying, like, Powell struggles a fair bit with high
player count, but that's due to the engine it runs on.
We're trying various methods to improve this, but we're
trying to get it further info to improve it.
Oh my god.
They're gonna analyze our data.
They're gonna analyze our data, guys.
They're trying to figure it out.
Kowalski.
Yeah, they'll personally study the server's data.
Guys, we need 20 plus dragoons in the server stat.
We gotta give them an authentic experience.
Our dragoon data being used.
Guys, it is for the future of server-powered kind.
Think of it.
inducing the vaccine for the future servers.
We are the guinea pig.
And gold jersey.
We got, all right, good, good.
That's good.
We got, we got enough dragons in there for the, for the,
they're pioneering, we're pioneering the solution.
They're going to put us in research papers as like a, a note
at the bottom.
I don't even remember what they're called.
Like, well, you know, like the credit, the, the credit notes
at the bottom of a research paper.
Like the sub note or whatever, like on Wikipedia, it's like
one, two, three, four, you click on it, give you a little
credit.
The annotations, like, as a thank you.
The footnotes, yes, we're going to be in the footnotes,
guys.
The footnotes of a paper for the data that we provided to
the server collectors, the server researchers.
Yeah, oh my God, they're here.
oh my god
anyway so that's the um that's the leak of the day uh from
the member uh from the member streams um so the lesson of
the day basically it doesn't hurt to always ask and shoot
your shot even if it seems like maybe you know maybe there's
nothing to be done it never to ask you know like maybe
something will come up with it anyway i have a partnership
with them somehow i i just stumbled my way into it like do
you want to do a partnership with us i was like fuck it you
know what and i didn't have to pay dollar sign dollar sign
dollar sign i think that's a win like i was willing to but
they're like no it's fine we'll put you on the best hardware
possible and i was like cool that's sweet like i was just
like whoa you didn't expect that thanks guys yeah i'm like
sweet um um other stuff so uh tomorrow i will not be i will
not be um participating in the second round of the Marvel.
I already told Member Goons this month not be participating
in the second round of the Marvel Rivals Tournament, the
elimination round, because I figured, I found out who my sub
is.
And the reason being is that the sub for me is a much better
player than me.
And they're like a one above all strategist player that's
been playing every day and streaming the game every single
day.
And I felt like it just wasn't fair to my team like you know
withhold that from them and so uh they are a much smaller
streamer than me they're like um they're very very small
streamer also also the fact that the person who was subbing
for me is a very small streamer like uh you know i don't i
didn't really see how much they get but i know they're very
small they're mostly primarily try to focus on tick tock
content from what i saw um but uh and uh I really want my
team to I didn't want to hold back my team and also because
I want my team because my team is filled with a lot of very
small streamers I feel like the money would uh the money and
the high placement they get with a stronger backline uh
would mean much more to them than it would be to me so I
don't want to uh hold them back or anything and so I I
talked to Boga about this I took me a I had a day to think
about it and everything too because they're like oh um
booger was just like um huge shout out to booger he's a
great tournament organizer he's a really good guy he said
like whatever you're comfortable with it doesn't matter to
me about anything else as long as you're comfortable like
that's all i want and uh he said that uh but yeah it's like
you know really good exposure to for my sub um especially uh
because i like i said there's a lot of small streamers in my
team they don't i don't know when they'll ever have another
opportunity to participate in such a big tournament with a
big huge prize pool as well with a lot of really big content
creators too so i thought about it i did think about it and
um i i told the team and i told boker i was just like hey um
i am i'm i'm really cool with the sub um fully taking over
for the rest of sunday um because like I feel like
performance wise the sub uh would be a better uh fit for the
team and also the fact that um he is a much better player
than me and it's not fair to withhold you know it's not fair
to withhold that from the team if they could perform better
with this with the sub I'd rather I'd rather they just go
fully with them because I do want them to do really well um
so so I'm just doing the panel and i'm going to be walking
around with my sunday free a good thing about it is for me
is that i am able to walk around artist alley as well
because i just didn't have any time the last two days like
today and yesterday yesterday so instead of uh persistent
tournament i would be walking around artist alley so i can
you know talk with the artists at off kai and also buy my
merch at off kai as well so i'll be using that time instead
um um on sunday and uh another thing i wanted to like uh
address about it is that i did see some comments about like
oh like um it was selfish of me uh to accept it because like
oh uh you don't have a lot of time or like uh to do this
tournament or anything um and i want because there was not a
lot of full context about what's going on but i spent a lot
of my time practicing for this tournament um i ever when
boker told me um um i did i basically i've been playing till
four to five a.m um every night uh after work was done and
so i'm just giving you guys the context and everything so it
wasn't like i wasn't like slacking off or anything and i
tried my best to like um like i literally the one time i
couldn't scream was the time they um the time they were like
hey we have a scream right now and i was in And it was a day
that I got drafted.
So I legitimately couldn't join even, like, I couldn't join
even if I wanted to.
Because it was a day I was drafted onto a team.
And they're like, we have a, we were screaming, we want to
scream now.
And I was just like, I legitimately couldn't, because I was
literally just in the collab.
If I was doing a solo stream, I would drop the stream and
then go straight to the stream.
But because I had a collab, the day I got drafted, and it
was also around the time that, like, uh they want there was
no like heads up or anything so if i had a heads up maybe i
would have cut this clap stream short but i can't drop a
stream right now and that's the only day that i wasn't i
didn't scrim or anything and all the other times um it was
just there was no scrim so i was practicing and rank um and
rank like every day every night basically but obviously i
felt that um it might not have been enough because like i
said i'm just playing catch-up with everybody else
and screaming every single day for like, you know, Marble
Rivals is their main content.
So, um, so obviously, you know, if another player whose
Marble Rivals is their main content would obviously be a
better player than me because I play, uh, I play it off
stream.
I play most of the time off stream and play as a side thing.
So obviously, you know, skill levels differs there.
So I did commit a lot of my time prepping for this
tournament.
it was just that um you know there was a lot of other
factors going in that was out of my control that was
unrelated to like my schedule or anything like my um um and
i found out they didn't um because like it was out of
control not related to any of my schedules or anything it's
just that the reason the main reason why i decided that my
sub fully played out is just because i found out that my sub
is a much better player than me and uh was a much better
player than me and i felt like if the sub is such a better
player than me uh like like like skill difference it just
wouldn't be fair to um to like withhold that opportunity for
the team and i was like i was willing to like step down so
that my team could have a better position um could have a
better position uh to perform play for an hour um anyway and
then um because of that I was just like be less stressful
for everybody involved because I didn't want to hold them
back or anything and um and I wasn't going to be able to
play an hour for tomorrow too so you know I feel I would
feel really bad if you know my sub did incredibly well to
get them to win their game and then they subbed me back in
and then like you know what if we lose i'll do that and then
i'll just i'd be like oh you know i don't want i don't want
them to go through that yeah yeah and also like it will also
let them have more time to scrim um more time to scrim with
their sub as well um and be able to um like more time to
scrim with them and get to know each other more instead of
just like having him for one game and you have no previous
experience whatsoever you know so it's easier uh if they
just go off the bat like scrimming uh with the sub much
earlier than just like being like all right donkey's gone
you're in just just drop drop him in
and it won't be a rival stream tomorrow but There will be
the wildcard club orientation as planned before that will be
at 12 p.m.
Yeah, that's at 12 p.m.
There will be the club orientation for the wildcard club.
And after that, I'm just going to be roaming around off guy
for artist alley.
I will say if you see me at the artist alley, I might not
be.
no not on all our channels by the way all our i will have
the waiting room up make later on but um the post off guy
will be on amali and it'll be on amali and rin's channel for
post off guy but for the off guy panel it is on all our
channels so all our channels will have the own stream for it
um so i'm just letting you guys know beforehand um that
there will be the it's just it's all the same stream by the
way it's all the same stream it's like a multi-stream on all
our channels and everything so that we can get as much
outreach as possible so um and there's that and yeah and
also like i want to add on for the tournament thing another
reason why is that for me there is always going to be
another tournament for me and i and i've i don't know maybe
i just care too much i told this i was talking about
memoryless i think i don't know maybe i just care too much
um but like i felt like but for the smaller streamers
because there were a lot of smaller streamers on my team and
I was like I don't know they're like they don't know when
there's going to be a next tournament for them and you know
being able to be part of this tournament is such a rare
opportunity too for some smaller streamers and so I don't
want to take that opportunity away from them I want to make
sure they have the best opportunity like the best experience
and opportunity they have because like we all know like two
days like the the round was not great.
The environment was very downer, like very sad and
everything.
Like everyone was really sad and everything.
So if there was a way for me to make the experience better
for them, I was willing to step down and let the sub take
over for me and let my sub take over for me if it would help
the team more because then it would be a much stronger
backline.
And for me, another opportunity for me to participate in a
tournament and Boker's a real one, you know, he was, he was
like, whatever makes you comfortable because he just wants
to be like, he just wants everyone to be having fun and
whatever, he doesn't care about like, you know, and I felt
so bad, I felt so bad.
I was like, I owe you one.
Like, I'm really sorry to put you in that position.
And, and, and I was just like, I was like, Hey, if this will
give if this would make improve the environment and um also
uh improve like my teams uh my team's gameplay and like
improve the um just improve the what's the word the team
cohesion and everything like that's fine with me because
there's always going to be another tournament for me i don't
like but for the smaller streamers they don't know when
there's going to be another don't know when like something
like they'll have a chance to be invited to something like
this again um because you know like a lot of tournaments is
based off of viewerships for those who don't know um so
that's why you see people inviting tournaments for people
and players outside of the like outside like that don't
might not necessarily play the game um because you know they
want to show the game to other um other communities and
everything so you know promote the game so it makes sense
like i know there's always this discord in rivals especially
in rivals where they're like why are they always inviting
non-rivals creators it's because it's very good at
advertising the game they want to advertise the game um they
want to promote the game to other communities and it makes
sense because you know if you're making tournaments for the
same right like making tournaments for the same players uh
in the marvel rival like not just marvel rivals but in the
within the video advertising it to the people who already
play so you're just advertising these the game to people who
are already playing the game so um so it makes sense that um
that uh uh that they want to invite the people outside of
the community um and so so that's why that's why like i i
wanted to give the smaller streamers a chance to be part of
something and have a better experience and that's why that's
why i was willing to uh be like it's okay um i don't mind
like i i think it would be better um better for everybody if
you know the sub just plays the entire the entire rest of
the tournament versus just playing one to two games and then
subbing me back in because of my schedule um and yeah that's
really all i have to say i do hope uh tomorrow because I'll
be very busy so I don't really know what's going to be
happening on tomorrow for my team.
But I do hope they do well.
I do hope they make it far.
And, you know, I just won what's best for them.
And I hope they get lots of good publicity, lots of good
exposure, and also lots of money, you know?
Everyone loves free money.
I hope they're able to do well.
I know they were
And, and, uh, yeah, but I hope that, uh, I hope that, you
know, they're able to have a good time at the tournament
tomorrow and everything.
I hope, like, the synergy improves.
I hope the synergy and chemistry improves.
I hope they, like, uh, are able to, you know, have a great
time for the tournament.
Anyway, guys, all right, let me catch up on the super chats.
thank you thank you glad you're not letting an ego or pride
get in the way take care and have fun dude thank you the
super chat thank you thank you um yeah i will say like the
environment of the tournament like just like everything i
told the members this and i don't mind telling you guys this
right now um but um i told the member goes this but i
haven't cried in a really long time from a tournament
because i've done so many of them but i uh after the
tournament was over i actually cried because i was so
overwhelmed and so stressed out like the energy and the
environment was just not not good on me and like i had like
a little like i had a cry about it because i had and i
haven't cried in a long time and that was when i knew I had
to tell Boger that like I think I I think it's best I'm
gonna think about it I told him I'm gonna think about it I
did cry the moment this tournament ended and I told him like
I'm gonna think I'll give you an answer tomorrow morning and
I talked to my friends and everything um and um because I I
hate I hate I don't want to let I don't want to uh what's
the word drag my team down my team down everything and i
want what's best for everybody and i think i just care too
much i want what's best for everybody and i want everyone to
have a good experience and i was just like i'm gonna think
about it i'm gonna talk to my friends and everything and
that like i said this decision wasn't made lightly and i was
just like um and then next morning i was like because i want
to make sure like the team the sub like like is able to do
stuff with my team instantly and not wait for like my
response and everything um and i was just like i was just
like okay it I woke up and I was like, all right, this is my
decision.
And I think it's best for the team for that.
And I know it's going to be the best for the team because
myself is a really, really good player.
Like I said, he streams and plays Marvel Rivals every day.
He is a much more consistent player than me.
Like I play for fun as an off-side thing.
Like I mostly play it off-stream because I do enjoy the
game.
I love the game a lot.
But if it's, I want what's best for my team.
um i know that like i said i know that they are uh like they
are smaller streamers and i want them to have a better
experience um than what we had during the round robin and
everything so yeah um yeah so that's basically everyone talk
about about it um but i'm still i'm looking forward to
tomorrow with the panel of the club orientation of the
wildcard club um and um i'm looking forward to uh i'm
looking forward to finally talking revealing more
information about the wildcard club because i know there's a
lot of questions about and everything um and everything will
be revealed tomorrow and if everything is not revealed by
tomorrow I will explain more in-depth about it after the
post-off Kai stream with Rin and Amelie and Mousy and
Aramel.
So if people are still confused after the panel and the
post-off Kai stream on Rin and Amelie's channel, the two
streams, I will explain more.
Because I also did not sleep a lot.
I didn't sleep a lot last night as well.
well because I had homework to do for the panel as well
because we had to study uh you know we got like we have like
a little we have to be like remember to do this this is this
and we have to get feedback for everything so um I had to
like look over that late at night as well so um so I had to
look through all of that and uh make sure that it's
everything that we want to say or about the notes or
anything if we want to remove anything the panel or anything
um so I had to do as well last night, so that's why I'm like
very tired.
Like I said, there's a lot of work going into it.
Also, Off-Kai, Artist Alley stuff.
If you are at Off-Kai and you see me at Artist Alley, most
likely I might not be able to say hi to people outside the
artists that I'm visiting the booths of.
And because of that, like if we might not be able to stop by
and say hi to any viewers and dragoons out there that are
also walking around off Kai just because like there's a lot
of artist booths we have to visit and I get tired very
easily my social battery right now is sort of really low at
the moment I'm hitting my limit I did because I've done two
meeting greets and I have a I did a panel yesterday and also
uh in a group setting so and i also did collab earlier this
week so my social battery is very low at the moment um and
um and i'll be using the remaining social battery after the
wildcard club panel to talk to the artists at afkai so um if
most likely um if you do see me at afkai roaming
My the the the handler might be like sorry Doki needs to go
to the next artist booth like Yeah like Doki might need to
go to the next booth She's gotta do this now So we might not
be able to do a lot of stops or like a lot of intermissions
and stuff So I'm really sorry if you see me you wanted to
say hi and you are not able to say hi or take a picture with
me I am so sorry We are just, we're sort of on a really
tight schedule.
There are a hundred booths selling Doki merch at Offcat.
So we gotta be able to get through a hundred booths before I
die in game, in Minecraft.
All right.
That's all the updates for today.
That's everything.
All right.
We're hitting, oh, I'm in.
update from the server to make it fair for everyone you're
hitting a power constraint x30 thus why it's so laggy what
is power world constraint x30 what does that mean did we
build too much is that what they're saying is it the tower
guys who all the people that are in the power server right
is it the tower like did we did we build too much what is a
power what do they mean by pal world constraint x30?
Oh, is it too much pals?
Oh, we're busting the server limits by 30.
But Toki, if we lose the tower, we're going to lose
communication with each other.
But Toki, we have you on multiple screens in the big bar.
Don't do that.
You're the Jesus combo, Eifen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, Eifen.
For some reason, it feels like you really, really want.
But because you asked so nicely, I will make sure I won't do
it.
Because that is definitely what you want, Eifen.
I will make sure I will never do it again, ever.
Oh, my.
Guys, they found the tower.
Guys, the staff has found the tower.
Guys, remember this day where Eiffen has convinced me
single-handedly with $20.
That will never do the Jesus combo ever again because he
asked so nicely.
Remember his name, everyone.
Eiffen.
Guys, I think they found the tower I
He doesn't talk for us Also, I is bid Thank you for the
magenta soup But thank you Thank you Does it mean Oh, what
do you mean by Palo will constrain x30.
All right.
How do I even respond to?
Are your viewers okay?
I think it's the tower of Babylon.
I don't even know.
How do I even respond
to?
Are your viewers okay?
I'm not.
Sure, let me define okay
Oh, apparently, okay, so apparently 20 pals per base running
24-7 with multiple bases in each area Thus, this turns into
an issue Alright, we might have to cut down the pals Oh, I
see Do you think cutting down the pals per base would
improve?
All right, all right, so we might have to we might might
have to set a new limit Griffin thinking with a super chat
thinking it's not the tower tower goons tower Tower Babylon
goons you are in luck the tower has nothing to do with this.
Oh, sorry tower Babel.
Sorry.
It's Babel.
I don't know why I keep saying Babel goons the tower Babel
goons
guys uh we can all still communicate with each other so we
do not have to destroy the tower of bable uh the tower lives
the tower is unrelated to the lag issues uh doug thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you are your viewers okay
it's no 100 100 times a 1 margin of error wait that means we
can make three towers God can't stop us now.
The tower is not the issue.
Solution.
We can make another tower.
We will make sure.
We will make sure that the tower will soon become an issue.
All right.
I could do so.
Yes.
All right.
Ask them how many pals they want to cut it down to.
All right, if you're not in the powwow server, your fate is
decided by, uh, uh, your fate is going to be decided by the
dragoons that are still in the server right now.
Uh, you can, okay, I'll be like, you can.
Doki, wait a minute, this is just a Zatsudon stream.
This is just a just chatting stream.
You've tricked us.
I thought you were going to be a gamer, Doki.
a game guys i say this is going to be like like it's just
one like i boot up armor core for five minutes like i'm
tired guys we're gonna call it here like we got bamboozled
uh i'm griffin thank you this is your chat thank you thank
you donkey i thought you're returning to gaming this is This
is just another chatting stream.
It's still a commentator, boy.
Hey, it's not gun and ball, though.
All right.
They also let me know they were fine with being laughed.
I was like, they are pretty much fine with a lot of things.
So go why?
You can do whatever you want to them.
Don't say it like that.
I said, they're fine with, they're like, they also let me
know.
You were fine with them being lab rats.
And I said, they're pretty much fine with a lot of things,
so go wild.
You can do whatever you want to them.
to you.
All right.
Sydney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, this is not a sponsored stream for Armor Court.
You tricked me, don't keep her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We are not fast.
All right.
Now we can finally boot up Armor.
The last time I played Armor Court was in June.
Oh my god.
That's not great.
It's been one month.
Golden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They will use the chosen palace and line the walls of the
next tower.
So is decreed.
We're going to create wall Maria.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Now we play armor core.
Let's see.
I need to remember the sound settings for armor core real
quick.
Oh, fuck.
Fuck, I forgot.
I forgot, like, I let past Doki put future Doki in a very
bad place.
All right.
Let's see.
Let me...
I mean... I forgot about where... I forgot where past Doki
put... I just remember where past Doki put us in.
premium yeah future problem is that's why this is the i
remember now i remember now we have why we haven't played
armor core in a month it's
been an entire month oh my god you are as beautiful as i
left you i was like future doki will solve this problem and
oh my god i keep forgetting i'm future dokey thank you for
pausing the ac series dokey i bought the game this week and
finished it today mike thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you you were as beautiful as i remembered you my
mecca um all right so i can't we're not going to do it the
sponsor today we're not doing a sponsor uh no actually Yeah,
if I'm still at the bar.
I'm thinking, do I take a sponsor?
Do we add a sponsor into the on the Mecca today or are we
good today?
You know what?
Today's a non-sponsored Mecca day.
I think, I think, you know what, I'm doing this pro bono for
the thrill of it, for the love of the game.
All right.
All right, we're not, I'm sorry.
I cannot, I'm sorry.
Future Doki has decided not to do this.
second mission
future past Doki left us left us with this mission and I I
don't know look I'll do two attempts guys we'll do two
attempts I don't remember how to play the game I well I'm a
first time viewer because you're in some bar what's a v2
thank you for the super chat thank you you all right we'll
do two attempts guys future doki is not future toki is a
little washed right now let me see if I remember how to play
this game the worst part all right oh I forgot that's that's
one of us Okay, there you go.
Oh, this is bad.
This is not looking good already.
This might not be good right now.
I might have to let...
Oh, 100%.
It does not feel like it's in my favor.
I really...
I don't even...
Guys, how do I heal?
Guys!
Does anyone...
I don't...
Remember how oh my god wrong button wrong button again guys.
How do I how he'll how he'll
No, it's already not looking good
How he'll I'm on mouse and key Okay, oh, I forgot about that
guy How he'll how he'll Q How to do the cool thing with the
shield how shield All
right, we got this guy All right How did how to do that the
cool Okay
do the cool shit.
Patrol?
No, it wasn't cool.
Patrol.
Um, the cool shield shit.
I don't remember.
I don't know.
Just press every button.
Surely something will work.
Surely, right?
Oh my god, I'm not.
Like the shield thing.
Go, go, go.
Follow this again.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That's not good for me.
I'm trying.
I swear to God.
Oh, no.
Sometime, no.
Big boom.
If it is in Osawa, a resident meditation.
Okay, we got...
I will get this guy out of the way.
Oh, that's not good.
It's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
Never mind.
Control R?
Alright, control R.
Oh, you.
Oh, my gosh.
You.
Okay, that's fine.
that's fine okay no not the surge please I'm not ready
oh my god don't even know if I hit it oh my god I'm
shooting everything I run him get this Oh, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh
Watch this.
I don't know what a VTuber is.
Oh, space.
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Why are they surrounding me?
He's like, that's where I got him.
That's how I killed him.
Okay.
All right.
I...
I don't know.
This might be the day where Big Boom might not be the
answer.
Doki, no.
That's blasphemy.
You can't say that.
Guys, this might be the day where Big Boom might actually
not be the answer anymore.
It can't be.
Doki, no.
No, it can't be.
How could you say that?
How could you say that is big boom?
Alright.
Slightly smaller boom.
Doki, no.
You just need a bigger boom, Doki.
Doki.
It's not...
It's not the boom's problem!
You just need a bigger boom!
That's it!
Okay.
I'll just chop that guy up real quick.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, that's a little easier.
That might actually be a little easier.
all right all right there we go all right there we go shut
your stink on start shooting this is fine this is fine this
is fine oh shit this might not be fine
Okay.
There we go.
Boom!
Okay.
We gotta keep the target busy, you heard the man with the
mad says!
You've got plenty of medals already, sir.
We want some of the glory too.
All right, nice.
Okay.
I'll get the little guys out of here.
all right that's good i think i always struggled with the
little guys for sure oh that's not what i meant to do that's
fine oh that's how i wanted to do but that's fine
okay all right that's okay
Are you serious?
He lives that!
I'm trying, I swear!
What living?
Woo!
Oh, this is bad.
I already have one.
Oh, hi.
Oh, shit.
A piece has 30%.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that!
I didn't mean to do that!
Oh, this is bad.
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't mean to do any of that!
That's the secret.
Are you serious?
AP at 30%.
Okay.
Where am I?
No!
Most definitely.
I'm saying most definitely was not okay.
Okay, I have an idea.
I have an idea, guys.
I don't know if it was better or worse, but I think I
gotta... I think I get the songbird out and then put what
was i on okay it was this but like
what was this on it was oh here you go just got add another
big boom as always it's always a big boom issue what's it
called which which one was the gun i use for this the um
What am I?
What did I equip?
I don't even remember.
What is this gun that I have on my back?
Oh, a stun needle.
Is this a stun needle?
Okay.
Wait, no.
It has to be the sunbird.
Okay, I have to use the stun needle on this.
Okay, that's the...
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
This is it.
My fellow dragoons.
I'm starting to think Big Boom isn't the answer.
I'm me.
A blasphemy!
How could you say that?
How?
Oh my god.
How the fuck did he get me?
Okay.
It's okay.
Look at the little babies out.
it's okay it's okay everything's fine there you go oh yeah
the deserter who pitched his pants and ran all right nice
oh that's not that's all i want he's gonna burn him
that's fine all right a big bada boom jared thank you for
the super chat thank you thank Yeah, bigger boom, exactly.
Bigger boom equals bigger win.
There's no way.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Are you serious?
Oh!
APs at 30%.
Oh, no.
Don't push the old girl too hard, huh?
Okay, that's fine.
There we go.
That should kill him.
They're ready to die, sir.
They're ready to die.
See, they want to die.
Oh, God.
Guys, remember, they want this!
Oh my god.
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
All right, we'll go over here.
You don't know, they don't know, they don't know, they don't
know, I'm here.
What are you doing here?
Wait, where are you?
Where are you?
I don't know where he is!
Okay.
It's five.
Oh my god, where the fuck are you?
Yes!
No!
this random okay okay are you fucking kidding oh god getting
jiggled everywhere
yes i guess but oh my god at least we can add numbers where
did these guys come from the front get those worms falling
for the mama's on his stretchers
okay okay wait i have a plan guys guys guys i guys i think i
know what to do i think i know what to do guys all right all
right where am i where What do I have on?
We have the POW bunker.
This is the POW.
Okay, maybe...
You know what?
Maybe I just need to shoot.
Maybe...
Maybe it's a shooting thing.
Maybe it's a shooting thing, guys.
Look at that.
realize how slow the gun is.
Okay, this might be bad.
This already is not looking good.
I forgot how slow the gun is.
I...
This is not good, guys.
Okay, this is a little slow, which is not ideal.
Okay.
That's fine.
all right it's okay we're fine we're fine we're fine all
right this is fine
it's okay we just shoot guys it's just a shooting thing like
what he said we just gotta keep shooting yeah i just want to
get rid of that that guy there we go okay nice just gotta
keep them busy you got plenty of metals already sir all
right we got this I did I hit him yeah did I hit him oh no
don't girl too hard huh okay i'm gonna shoot the little guys
though oh i overheated it
all right we're gonna shoot the little guys though oh my god
i think the flamethrower will be so good at that moment
right now ah sit down out of the way i'm not ready for that
okay
I swear to God, I'm trying!
I swear to God!
Damn right you are!
Where are you?
Wait!
Go multiply your rifle training and see if you can learn to
do something useful.
Oh my god, I hit him.
I hit him, I think.
I don't know.
I'm always so confused.
Did this fucker?
Okay,
I just gotta kill these guys.
Please!
I don't have the time!
There's so many things on my screen!
Okay.
There's too many things on my screen right now.
You guys be kidding me.
It's not Michigan.
All right.
That's okay.
That guy.
That guy!
Oh no.
Guy.
Okay.
Oh.
Dead.
that too all right there's a big boy here that really
doesn't like me
oh all right the tiny guys left did it guys big pooh I'm
sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Technically, it's still a big boom run.
I just got a little gun with me.
I got the big boom did it.
It still counts, guys.
It still counts.
Goodbye, G1 Michigan.
You'll always be my Oishi.
Adrien, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
counts.
Big Boom was still there.
Look at that.
You bash your head against the wall, eventually you'll win.
Little booms.
Little booms compliment the big boom.
You did your job, 6-2-1.
Michigan knew the score.
Balaam's withdrawn from Rubicon.
The politicians will be fighting their war now.
Where there's world there's blood that's how it's always
been six to one big boom
all right
that took a lot what if i just end stream after i'm joking
i'll keep playing i'll keep playing I was like, oh, that
took so much out of me.
Oh my god.
I'm so tired.
Alright.
What you did?
I'm joking, guys.
We're going to keep going.
We're still playing.
I'm JK.
JK.
We're still gaming.
It was intense.
Alright.
Unknown territory.
Head down into an unknown territory.
Find the coral convergence.
Eliminate your pursuer.
How far am I in this game, by the way?
Yeah, I'm trying to browse play video games again.
No, I'm still playing, guys.
Guys, don't leave.
Some people actually thought I was ending.
I'm still going.
We received a request from Archivist.
continue the advanced survey there was something else too
orders for raven advanced survey squant we've received some
concerning information that an ac has been quietly following
your trail yeah archivist cannot tolerate unauthorized
surveys that will put its coral interests at risk if you
spot this rogue we could technically finish this game today
right Where there's coral, there's blood.
Remember that, 6-2-1.
Alright, we're gonna finish this game today.
I'm gonna go order food.
What do you mean?
Yeah, I said we're almost done.
Okay.
What do you mean I need to get...
What do you mean?
Alright.
halfway point we almost up first okay guys we're almost done
with this game we're almost done with the okay uh
guys our goal is to finish the first alright the first
ending how many missions do I have left for the first ending
you need to play it through three times wait you have to go
through oh until you oh until you Jared to give a super chat
thank you thank you i'm about to finish the four like nine
to ten okay maybe not i was gonna say i feel like if it was
like five then i'll i'm good with that if if it was five
that was like that's doable that's that's doable but ten
missions is a little bit not doable
all right here we go main system activating combat mode
commence mission make your way down to the next oh my god is
that the tower oh my god we're back in the we're back on the
tower of abel guys you can never escape the tower
all right oh
i have to go down oh yeah i destroyed this guys this was
last month's dokey guys
I'm joking that this future dokey has to remember what she
did it's like momentum.
I'm trying to take Polaroid pictures trying to be like, what
did I do?
Oh no, now nobody will speak the same language.
Oh shit.
It's a lot of worms.
You got my little laser gun.
They're like little booms.
Technically they are like little booms.
guys.
The towers have fallen.
They're costing us 15 and 20.
It has to be Duke.
Wait, you guys.
What do you guys actually...
No!
That everybody has to speak their own language.
We created 20 new languages now.
How would you all communicate?
And I wasn't there to see the destruction of it.
Why did no one tell me?
Oh, I'm tired.
I'm going to do explosion.
I'm going to...
The town turns out that they were eating 10 to 20 frames.
The tower is no boy!
I was gaming.
I was gaming too hard.
You doing this all.
Oh, no.
Reading pods for the mealworms.
Looks like they're out of commission now.
Raven, I'm reading something behind us.
Did anyone capture the moment when the towers fell?
Era has ended.
We lost the universal language.
Did anyone film it?
Never forget.
It's on VHS.
No deal with a mercenary who went in alone, they said.
Turn on the TV in.
J对.
Sears both of us are too dangerous to keep around.
What's that?
That's me.
Oh, hey, rusty.
I'm Raven.
We're best friends, rusty.
Oh, wait.
I thought it froze before hose.
So, buddy.
Who needs you?
You?
what do you mean I don't want to dance to there too but this
time I don't have any other choice oh god he's so fast but
rusty six two one bros the whole poor hose that's your job
now
nice you never change you're not Oh no.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Do this.
I know you can do better than that.
Can I?
Don't let the women tempt you!
We're supposed to be together!
Wait, did that not hit him?
Can't tell.
This has been a real eye-opener.
You're strong.
A threat.
Damn right I am.
What?
Okay, that's illegal.
That's actually legal.
What he just did to me.
Oh my gosh, he keeps dodging me, isn't it?
That's not the only thing that makes you dangerous.
Oh, he wants me.
Tell me, buddy.
What drives you?
me buddy we're still in i don't know where he is sometimes
like i i don't know where he is
like he fucking runs away
there we go we're still in he still thinks about me even
when we're fighting he's like how why can i never forget you
buddy there's no graver's threat without purpose call me
buddy guys it's not dead yet you up
we've lost all signs of steel haze he's escaped that's all
right I wanted him to escape just so we can meet again I let
him escape guys so we'll meet again I'm picking up a major
coral response coming from the bottom of the pit let's keep
moving Raven we just yearn for the battle of the I could
never find I could never find a mecca like you.
Every fight I do, it's not the same, Rassi.
It's not the same, Raven.
The thrill you give me, Raven, in our 1v1s.
I see the vision.
I see it.
Institute City.
Of course.
No wonder we couldn't find it.
underground.
I need to prepare before the corpse move in.
Head back to base and rest up.
Every other Rubicon I fight, it was never as good as you,
Raven.
You make me feel something today.
That's what they said.
Did you not hear it?
He said that.
He said that in the scene.
Yeah, I can't believe Rusty said that, guys.
I You heard it right you heard it guys right I See them so
clearly the voices of the coral My family Brothers and
sisters consumed by the fires of Ibis Only a few survived
and then they kiss They finally formed a new flock.
Oh See, you're still alive.
I knew it.
I knew we met the fab.
We met her parents.
Let's take a look, Raven.
Incoming comms.
I get to meet her parents, guys.
I think they like me.
Let me tell you a story before you go.
All right, Walter.
There once was a scientist.
Wait, is this scientist you?
You branded his family to delve into the secrets of Coral.
His work yielded a carnival of horrors.
surgery included but there was another scientist he took his
colleagues sins upon himself and set it all ablaze died with
no regrets there's a lesson in this story once something's
alive it doesn't die easy six to one story time's over it's
time for work damn that sucks bro all right we got the
rubicon research facility all right what's next reach the
coral convergence eliminate two acs dispatched by the
corporations and reach the coral convergence all right time
to fight a lot people you saw the ruins institute city the
mausoleum of the sinners who caused the fires of ibis The
Coral's right there.
Waiting.
Archibus has ordered us to discontinue the survey and hand
things over to their own AC squad.
621.
We're done with the corporations.
Wipe out the Archibus AC squad and get to the Coral first.
When this job is over, I'll tell you.
tell you about the last of my friend's requests.
Okay.
Alright, he'll finish his story after that.
Alright, let's go.
I gotta know the end of the story.
6-2-1.
From here on out, I...
Yeah?
I would.
I would!
Oh, it's indie time.
That's true.
We're done with Corpus.
I realized becoming an indie gave me more money I make my
own missions let's go this is a majorly majorly important
mission Jared thank you the super chat thank you thank
you all right holy shit whoops
I'll head her this way V2 snail come in requesting backup we
have insufficient force to ensure success these Institute
relics are such best I actually don't know I'm right behind
you whoop oh shit wait they did go wait a minute wait how
did they go I decided to ignore Archivist's orders did you
V2 snail come in the raven has landed I'm requesting backup.
Oh shit!
I fucked up!
It's okay, there's so much carnage going on, they don't
know!
Oh my god, I'm just gonna brute force this.
Yoki staff.
Oh my god, I cannot see.
I cannot see.
What?
How did I miss that?
Oh my god!
How did that happen?
He was in front of me!
Oh my, that's crazy.
I don't even know how that happened yet.
I don't even, I don't know, I don't know.
I don't know.
Where are
you?
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
All right, there's this guy now.
Stupid water boy.
I gotta get water boy.
Got that water boy!
AP at 30%.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
I'm already dead.
I'm dead.
I need like
You fucker!
Oh, I'm so dead No He's so slow He was so slow
He was right there
all right okay okay okay okay okay i got it i got it figured
it out i just whiffed a couple of shots
all right i have an idea let's go v2 snail come in
requesting backup we have insufficient force to ensure
success You take him.
I'll wait.
I'll wait it out.
I'm gonna wait it out.
I'll watch.
Is he doing here?
Okay.
It's alright.
patience is key guys patience is key you're
still shooting at them that's right let them fight this guy
is still at it oh shit he saw me wait how did he see me
how did she see me at 30 percent oh my god are
you serious no
no no no no no no no no no no oh god oh my god where are
this where is that bitch
okay Where is she?
Oh, God I'm one HP.
I'm one HP
No I called and I answered Are you serious?
It will take me to the top of the Vespers.
Ah All right, it's not fair.
It's a 2v1 It's it's that That's it.
It's time to bring back the big boys.
It's time.
That's it.
I'm bringing it back.
Yeah.
Alright.
Now it's time for three big booms.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
That's fucking it.
We wait.
We have insufficient force to ensure success.
These Institute relics are such pests.
That's the Ark of a ZC squad.
Isn't that one worth the records?
Looks like the drones are keeping them busy.
Watch this, though.
Yeah.
Alright, the drones are keeping them busy, guys.
Not you though.
Yes!
See,
keep shooting.
Keep shooting.
I'm cleaning up.
I move while high.
Prepare to die.
Yeah.
Okay.
They're still getting shot at.
I mean, you're still getting shot at right now.
Wait, they're not.
They're trying to find me.
Oh, they're trying to find me.
They're trapped.
Hey, that's not fair.
Where are they?
I lost track of them.
But
the assistants, please.
There's so many things on my screen.
Serious bitch!
Oh,
this is bad for me though.
This is bad for me.
She's so fast.
Oh god.
No!
Oh, what?
What?
been exterminated withdrawing request for backup what
happened apologies for the disturbance v2
what what happened where did she come from okay okay okay
this time this time okay okay okay we're gonna wait We're
gonna bait her out.
I have a plan now.
Okay, I haven't planned.
Do you see that?
The moment they're stunned?
Oh, fuck.
They don't know.
They didn't know.
Guys, guys, guys.
She didn't see.
They didn't see.
That's good.
They didn't see
The independent mercenary Decided to ignore Archivist's
orders Did you?
V2 snail come in The Raven is landing Requesting backup No,
no, they don't know, they don't know Do you think they know?
Oh shit, they know, they know, they know, they know They
know, they know, they're coming They're coming for me
Okay, they know now They definitely know now.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Commander, V2 Snail.
Please come in.
This is no fair.
That is not fair.
Baylon was a sinking ship.
Dark of us as stars on the rise.
And me, I'll be well rewarded.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
Okay, all right, I got her against the wall That's the I die
with I take us
Oh shit No repair kits remaining Yes, oh my god.
Yes, okay.
All right, no more repairs Oh, what do you mean?
There's two more targets What you mean Secure the area,
6-2-1 Okay, just securing the area Looks like you're clear
Keep moving There is a checkpoint eventually And where does
this eventually hit?
How would you even buy eventually?
Oh A job does not seem done yet, guys.
The vascular plant, it's still here.
The fuck is that?
What is that in the water?
I don't know where, yeah, I'm not fucking going down there.
This chest?
Whoa!
All right, now I know what's down there.
Okay, now I know.
Well then.
Yeah, I don't think I'm gonna go down there, guys.
This does not seem very ideal.
Wheels and fire.
Okay, I got scared.
like they're calling to us
man guys where do I go is this way just there okay but where
is it down there though guys gotta be very specific where is
it down there I'm not just gonna be like over there
my scatter isn't picking up anything guys i need the
checkpoint
guys let's get the let's get the checkpoint first guys
okay it's over there joki is over there the response is
getting stronger we're nearly there six two one already got
one okay
all right that's good to know it should just be the left at
the end of the bridge all right let's let's check it out the
left side my left or your left this side is it here
why is my scanner not picking anything up guys
oh shit i'm not making any shit oh my
there's a wheel there oh i see it
No, no, I'm here.
Left shoulder ammunition at 30%.
Where did the wheel go?
Oh, it's like right below me.
Oh my god, that wheel's running away.
Like a little bitch.
I say as I jiggle peek the wheel.
Ow.
Right shoulder ammunition at 50%.
Yeah.
It's okay, the wheel doesn't know how to climb.
Where is he?
What the fuck?
There we go.
Alright, that should be everything.
Oh my god, that was not everything.
Okay, I hear another wheel.
How many wheels are there?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right, another wheel down.
I gotta be more careful now.
Oh, my God.
It's like, it's like I'm like stuck in the deserted.
Like, I'm on a boat and there's like sharks circling me
right now.
Oh shit, I killed the kids.
Were they trying to like, like, fuck and make more wheels or
some shit?
Is it?
It's okay.
You're doing really good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Ultra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
That should be all the wheels.
I'm.
doing it so slow, too.
I'm like very slowly riding over.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
That's the border.
Let's try to cheese it.
I'm hugging the edge right now.
Okay, I'm almost there.
Oops.
at 50% all right here we go here we are 621 I'm looking
archivist will be here soon investigate before they arrive
okay resupply okay we got the resupply
there we go that's down here
Here we go.
Do not be afraid.
Why would I have to be afraid?
What do you mean?
It seems like a very safe spot.
It looks so safe and friendly.
Red means good.
Right?
Red means good and safe.
a response it's a sea weapon what the fuck what the fuck is
that
the ibis series still functional i read you this bro that's
just that's a Gundam what the fuck wait that's not fair she
brought like this is not a 1v1 this is not you always say
This is the last job, but it's never the last job.
I'm starting to think there's it's never I'm starting to
think that it's always I'm starting to think he's lying
about the last job, guys.
At this point,
oh shit oh shit oh my god how do you dodge that
okay my
god i just go straight into it that was my bad
oh i'm so fucked right now Keep it up six to one and can't
take much more of this.
Yeah, no shit Oh,
yay nice I did it.
Yeah, all right Okay, never mind.
I guess big boom is always the answer.
I
Yeah, what wait wait a minute
Wait what wait wait a minute wait wait a minute wait I
thought but big boom okay Jesus Christ oh my okay I'm
I'm trying Oh shit Oh I'm fucked I got fucked up
We were so close Oh we were so close That we almost first
tried it too We were so close If I do my second form, I
would have played like if I would have played more like a
little bit
I'm just so disoriented by her.
She's so fast here.
So that's like
Jesus Christ Who am I fighting Malena?
Jesus!
Okay, this might not be a run.
This is not the run.
This is absolutely not the run.
Focus 6-1.
You have to focus.
This is not the run, guys.
Oh my god, I'm just gonna die.
Just kill me.
Just kill me, bro.
We're resetting this.
We're resetting this run.
I'm not gonna reset this run.
Alright, I got this.
Gundam Millennia.
Alright.
Now I get it.
When I was like, get ready for Dark Souls.
I was like, we can't think about getting this.
This is Armored Core.
I was like, wrong stream, guys.
This time request Okay, now Like how Oh my god, this is
worse.
This is worse.
This is the worst right?
How did I do it before?
Are you serious you dodging this
Oh my Yeah, no shit yo Oh shit, I know.
I know.
Oh, where did she go?
Why did she, how did she show up on Bombay?
Okay, that's...
Okay, all right.
Okay, let me focus up.
She's just here to bait.
She's just baiting me.
She's actually just She's just baiting me right now Here we
go
Okay Believe me, I'm trying Oh my god, you fucker
Oh shit
Oh.
Okay.
Focus!
Oh, God.
I think I dodged it.
I can't tell.
Where did she go?
Shit.
No!
Okay.
This is bad for me.
I don't have shields left.
Wait, it's coming back.
But it's the flag.
I don't know.
That didn't work.
The plan didn't work.
I don't know.
I thought it would be...
I thought it would go different in the island.
No!
You!
I'm so mad.
She's had to, like, get stunned so far.
away from me like 80 80 miles away
the worst part was i was i why not
like this it was always so far whenever she gets stunned
oh my god okay okay no jesus She's just so far.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Up here.
Oh my god, you security measure to keep Roman cons safe.
Come on.
Yes!
That should be directed.
No!
Oh my god, I know!
Raven, we're in danger.
I know!
Okay.
You have to focus.
All right.
Enemy coral response.
Silent.
Okay.
wait it's coming back
I don't know I just I'm cool
oh my god
okay just again I don't know I freaked out I freaked out it
looks like he was gonna fuck me up guys
okay oh I know but me too Oh no, no!
No!
She comboed me!
Oh, I got comboed.
I got comboed.
Oh, she comboed me.
Oh, the goddamn combo.
I know, what the fuck was that attack?
God.
Jesus Christ You know I Jesus They're designed to prevent
Coral disasters A security measure to keep Robocon safe
Okay, I got him But now their original masters are gone Yeah
Oh, I'm trying
Oh my god You've been...
You asked you what?
Oh my god, no wonder your parents abandoned you as a child.
No wonder, no wonder nobody loves you.
Nobody loves you.
You have to live... You're never gonna find a husband.
You're never gonna find a good diversion.
You're gonna fucking die diversion.
I don't care.
Your parents don't love you and you'll never find a husband.
Oh my god, I hate this is the worst run.
This is actually the worst run Like I don't even have repair
kits anymore I'm not a fucking spit this week.
I bet that he was a smith at the soup, but thank you
Wait, it's coming back It's reactivating I don't know why I
did that I'm just so I'm just I'm just I Even though I know
it does zero damage.
Jesus Christ.
Like, how?
You can take it.
Like, don't worry.
You can.
That's it.
I'm bringing it out.
Where is it?
All right.
it it's time for the gun it's time cat dodge fire yeah
fucking dodge this bitch I think it's controlled by corn too
oh you fucking
That's right!
Dodge fire!
Better fucking take damage!
Fucking dodge fire!
Dodge this!
Oh shit!
What the fuck happened to me?
Focus 61, you have to focus!
Oh my god.
I'm just, I'm...
Okay, maybe fire's not it.
He's too...
Maybe fire's not it, guys.
I'm losing track over.
Are you serious?
Guys, fire might not be it.
I'm sorry, I think fire might not be the call.
She's dodging the fire.
That's it.
Fire doesn't work.
Yeah, big boom, I have actually been better.
All right.
We'll try minigun.
I can't be the first the my first attempt was my best
attempt too
You fucker you fucker you fucker you fucker the fact that
she like ran away the moment too
Oh my
Jesus Oh My god
Okay Jesus Christ Oh Okay
God, he's so
fast There you go Okay
Here we go.
We gotta wait now.
We gotta wait for this fucker to reactivate.
I'll just do the little pokes until then.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
I couldn't, I couldn't stab her.
was two.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Jesus!
Oh my god, didn't mean to do that.
I actually did not mean to do that.
No, I cannot!
I was trying to do the expansion, but it wouldn't let me,
and I could dash in her for some reason.
Goodbye.
Why did I dash into her?
I was trying to arm her up, but it wouldn't let me, straight
into her oh
this fucker this actual this fucker okay oh shit i oh i
wanted to blow my nose
the timing could have been more wrong for me there's no 161
behind this series are no ordinary weapons they're designed
to prevent coral measure to keep robicon safe okay now their
original masters will walk on destroy it before it destroys
oh god i'm near lock i'm actually locking you now
jesus christ i swear to guys i swear to guys like this
okay where did she go where did she go i'm so lost where did
she go
Oh my god, I got it!
I was so confused where she went.
Wait, it's coming back.
It's reactivating.
Is this what the Ipa series is truly capable of?
environment it won't stop until we destroy its generator
oh my god locked in okay sorry sorry sorry sorry i'm muted
myself and i i was so locked in now i didn't even realize
i'm muted myself i was so locked in i was so locked in
Are you serious?
You fucking whore!
Okay, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
All right, I know what to do.
Wait, is that my...
Okay, no, no, no.
That's not what I want.
That's not...
Wait, was I on Powerbunker or Pulseblade?
Oh, shit, I fucked up, guys.
Guys, what sword was I on?
I was Powerbunker, right?
I don't remember what sword I was on.
I pressed the wrong one.
Okay.
Okay, okay, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Sad.
default This is it
Oh, I'm sick Oh no
Oh There you go.
Don't worry.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Jesus.
Where did she go?
I can't take much more of this.
Boom!
It just...
Just shoot.
It just start shooting.
It's just just start shooting.
Just bring a gun Wait, it's coming back
Is this what the Ipa series is truly capable of?
Okay, where is she?
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Pew, pew.
Okay.
Pew, pew, pew, pew,
pew.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Where am I?
Okay.
I don't know where she is.
where is she?
oh no no it's gonna
blow me get out of there 6-2-1 oh wait why is that fucking
worse the demon the demon guns did it The float, the default
gun.
Never disrespect the rifle.
What?
No, don't get me.
I record.
Oh shit, thank you for that.
The bullet, pew, pew, pew.
If the basic rifle was the key, It was the key!
It was a tired time!
Oh my god, I think you would think that would work!
Connor, thank you for the 50 gift and chips!
Thank you, thank you!
Holy fucking grass, you've earned these five dollars!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
You always works.
Saber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Frisky-Husky, thank you for the super chat.
You just proved that Lizzo Boom was the way to go.
No!
Big Boom was still there.
It was still there.
We just needed little booms to go with the big booms.
The biggest control of the core.
occupying forces swiftly commandeer the entirety of
institute i did it i told you i never i don't need to swap
my builds guys discovered a well no wheelchair wins the
institute kept secret fearing they were beyond human control
a group of sea weapons i'm in prison the central coral
control system bomb thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you
Archibus also claimed a tower I'm just happy to blame to
beat Mecha Melania the vascular plant they toil to repair
the plant and extend its reach beyond Rubicon's atmosphere
oh shit yeah your third party that's against the rules ref
front no longer had the power to stop them and tool thank
you for the super chat thank you the fact that almost first
tried her too that's so frustrating it was so close as the
end drew near I'm being one of the hardest bosses in the
game, Doki.
Thank you.
We beat it with default gun number one.
I found a message addressed to you.
621.
A friend of mine sent a request.
Now, this one comes from me.
You know what hidden date.
ibis should have wiped the coral out but it survived okay
and it's been steadily multiplying ever since now the coral
convergence is growing at an exponential rate that's good
eventually it'll spill out from rubicon and contaminate
that's my my girlfriend's parent like family must be burned
six to one even if that means we're igniting the fire that
scorched the stars this isn't an order it's a legacy my
fallen friends entrusted this duty to me and now it's my
turn to hand it on wait why do i have to kill my
girlfriend's family feed the fire let the last cinders burn
i have one last the coral is evil
You keep telling me this will be the last job!
Ira, what does he mean?
Now, I finally understand what does he mean, girlfriend?
Why is he saying you're bad?
I thought you were...
You can't be evil, Ira.
It's time for us to escape.
Here's your...
The final, final, final job.
All right, you'll use an old gen instead of your usual craft
on this mission.
This AC is main from junk parts.
This performance leaves much to desire.
No.
Okay.
Okay, I still have my big booms.
I still have my big booms.
It's okay, guys.
I built it.
My girlfriend built it for me.
I can't believe they put us on sewer duty.
No.
Oh,
shit.
Oh, whoops.
Well, you should have told me that earlier.
Well, that's my bad.
Whoops.
Alright, jamming around, rupture, creating air.
round launcher as his left hand okay oh i can just jam it
okay disadvantage let's find a way around them if they do
spot you your left hand weapon is equipped with jamming
rounds they spot me hey you get back nope wait they're not
with us do you think they spotted me
Nah, right?
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
I could just kill him.
Wait.
Whoops.
But I don't think he knows.
Oh, shit.
ECM!
Damn it.
I can't lock on.
It's okay.
Now's our chance.
Oh, shit!
Wait, what was he?
What is this guy doing?
Wow!
Wait, I must grab that!
It's okay, it's okay.
This is the risk I'm willing to take.
Alright, wait, wait, I got this.
He doesn't know.
Okay.
Wait, that's just lore.
He doesn't know.
Right behind you.
Oh my, it was just lore.
I can't believe it.
Hey there It was just lore.
I did all that for lore.
The lore will save me
No, oh
Five Yeah, they don't know I'm here There we go.
It's fine.
You don't know.
I hit him though.
Oh shit!
There we go.
I need stealth.
I have guns.
You can't hit him?
Oh shit, wait, hello.
I can see you there.
I keep forgetting they're like...
There you go.
Nice.
The area is clear.
Let's keep moving.
Oh, wait, is that, uh...
Yeah, that's a lift.
Weeeee!
That's right.
stealth is optional i should stop my offshore bank account
will pay this offs oh maybe not here
where no no oh oh oh raven the search lights where
neutralize the fugitive she doesn't know watch this we're
not far from our destination
he doesn't know we've got eyes on the independent oh he does
but where am i supposed to go up here what's this i've
checked it's not a trap As you think they know?
Do you think they know?
Do you think they know I'm here?
Emergency beacon intercepted.
Chief's coming to pick you up.
There we go.
Here we go.
I don't think they know.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, it's alright.
The searchlight don't see me.
If I don't see them, they don't see me.
I got hugged the corners.
See, I told you.
No, you don't.
Oh, no, maybe they do.
Maybe they do.
If the target resists, you are authorized to use lethal
force.
Stop, Raven, by all means, necessary.
You have your orders.
Oh.
No, it's fine.
We're so healthy.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Vibeless no longer 1v100.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God we got an escort.
We are bodyguards here.
Hurry.
Let's go!
Her bodyguards here!
Oh my god, I don't have to do anything.
The carry is here, I get to be on her backpack!
Oh, we're clear now.
That's so true.
We did it!
We did it, Carla!
Hope is here!
Oh,
we're alive.
Oh, my god.
We're fucking alive.
We made it.
Look at that.
Didn't spend any money, too.
See?
We don't need stealth.
It's only a choice, and it's the wrong choice.
Alright.
Alright, we're back.
We're back with our mechs.
Augmented human.
C4621.
Entering standard mode.
Incoming comms.
Back in your old AC?
Yep.
You were made for each other.
The fact that you're still alive means that Walter made the
right bet.
Alright.
You deserve to know what we've been fighting for.
I'll get you introduced.
with the next mission all right after next mission is the
ending choice should we save that for to next week guys or
should we do it oh this sounds like very all right let's all
right do we do that do we do the next mission now or save
that for next week the next last mission when will the
mission end don't worry guys this is the last job
all right what is next mission I'll check the next mission
out all right defend the control tower all right we'll
defend it we'll do this mission now we'll do the mission now
there's just defending One more job.
Let me tell you a story, Taurus.
After the fires of Ibis burnt the planet.
Final job, for real.
A secret organization formed, hiding in the ashes.
Overseer, the association of observers.
Yeah.
They monitored the coral's growth.
Ready to burn it before the collapse came.
That was their mission.
Our mission, me, Walter, and our fallen friends.
RAD was always a front, a side hustle.
It's time for me to get back to my real work.
Let's get down to brass tacks.
You've been to Xylem before, right?
The floating city created by the Institute?
It's hiding a secret.
Little something to prepare against the coming collapse.
We need to get to it and fast.
RID's entire team of hackers is going to be working to take
control of Xylem.
I want you to deal with Archivus when they come running to
see what we're up to.
Seriously, this would be the last job for real this time.
This is it, guys.
Like Carla said, the last job for real.
Oh, the moon blade?
Do I even have it?
I think I forgot.
Oh, I do.
Do I replace it with my power bunker?
Is the blade better?
Is this blade better than my power bunker?
It's so tiny.
But it's cool.
Oh, it's a range energy weapon.
Alright, we'll use that for...
Oh, it's only on my left.
It's only...
I'm not...
ambidextrous?
What do you mean I can only use it on my right hand?
Alright.
How am I not ambidextrous?
Check the preview video?
Alright.
Oh, is this?
I mean, I mean...
Alright, yeah, it looks pretty cool, yeah.
For real.
I will try Try it out.
Hey.
I know, right?
You can't be evil.
You're my girlfriend.
You keep telling me that you're not real and you're just a
voice in my head.
But I know you're real, girl.
You're real in my heart.
Wait, actually, before like all the restaurants closed, let
me you.
I realize before all the restaurants close down, let me
order food for myself.
I feel like that might be a smart thing to do.
Yeah, I'm gonna order.
Um, I want to do this.
Um,
well, I'll put, I'll order sauce.
And then let's see.
I'm gonna get this.
I want oh pudding would have caramel pudding and then what
do i want do i need like snacks what i oh i eat a wrap i
need a lot today i realized so i didn't treat myself a
little bit i'm gonna treat myself a little bit um
all right i already did this all right doria i love doria
all right well because it was going to close in like 18
minutes so i ordered it right now no i've been eating too
much jolly leaves it's time
all right i'm assuming i'm protecting the tower over here
so where where are they gonna come from that'll buy us in
time it's like you're in position chatty how much longer
till we have control Give me five minutes And the corpse
will I'm picking up an archivist Yeah Well guys have showed
up early Looks like you're up already Taurus Can I big boom
this right now?
Oh nice Don't let them near the tower Taurus
See you We've got access to support Weaponry Use them if you
need the help Oh shit, they're over there.
I see you.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, they're so fast though.
Here I see you.
Four minutes left, the system is ours, tourist.
Oh shit.
I'll grab these guys first.
Oh, fuck!
Oh shit!
I can't
fly too fast!
Oh, nice, we're five.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck!
It's five.
Oh my god, where are they coming from?
Three more minutes.
Oh, this is too much.
This is too much.
It's too stressful.
We've got snipers.
Hey, tourist.
Go clear them out.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
I thought I killed him.
What did he did?
Okay.
This is not good.
Oh, this is not good.
Oh, shit.
Two more minutes and it's hours.
I thought it was two minutes, 20 minutes ago.
Wait, we've got something else.
What?
What even?
Make sure you don't miss, Taurus.
What?
Um.
Ah.
Trouble now.
Looks like they're falling over each other to get your
autograph, Taurus.
Oh.
Oh, get this guy out of here?
You've been working like a dog.
Must be Walzer's influence.
Guy's a real slave driver.
Just one minute to go, Taurus.
Okay.
Give me 30 seconds and we'll have full admin access.
Just a little more, Taurus.
Okay.
We did two repair kits remaining.
Oh, did it.
Okay.
All right, we did it.
All right, it's fine.
The towers are fine.
Good job holding out, tourist.
Now I'll show you what this city really is.
Not even that hard, guys.
It's not...
It's so easy.
Both towers are still there.
technically oh shit what oh the city's back it's like
Atlantis we're reverse Atlantis not
even hard you can think Walter for the tip thanks Walter I
give you the colony ship oh shit oh my god it just looks
like a giant gun oh my imagine if you can have an ac unit
holding that giant ship gun
there's more while you were captured archibus finished the
world thank you now that's the atmosphere and it won't be
long till they take it all well
before it's too late of course we can't just walk up to the
plan and light a match no we're going to need something one
last mission guys this is the last last job one last job
this one right here is the last last The last job.
You're right.
You're so right.
You're so right, Ira.
Of course.
Anything for you.
How dare they?
They hate my girlfriend.
The shared potential of humanity and the quarrel.
Raven.
I need to ask you something.
Yeah?
She's so right.
How dare they?
They just hate our relationship because they're jealous.
That's so true.
I wonder what choice Doki would make.
No new messages.
They hate her because she's not human.
They're racist.
And Dola, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They don't understand our love.
All right.
I'm going to call it here, guys.
I have a long day tomorrow.
So we're going to call it here, guys.
All right.
Thank you all for watching.
See, guys, I know how to play video games, guys.
I still got it.
I still got the gaming in me, chat.
But I hope you guys enjoy the stream.
I hope you guys enjoyed.
enjoyed the destruction of the Tower of Babel live on I
can't believe it we recreated the destruction of Tower of
Babel hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and
if you step for me um head to bed guys you deserve it I'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys Bye!